[Music]
thank you
hello dear friends welcome to this
program I'd like to know one of our
favorite programs because we have the
opportunity to interact with you with
your Bible questions
on my left I have the company of my dear
Pastor C.A Murray one of the associate
speakers for Secrets unsealed uh thank
you Pastor Murray to for being with us
here in this panel always a pleasure uh
glad to be with you thank you and we're
also happy that you are tuning in as you
can tell we have an impressive amount of
questions here and if we have an answer
your question yet is because we have
many many ahead of your question but we
promise that we will do our best to get
to your question if you would like to
send in your questions you can do it so
at this at the following email address
TV at some tv.org again this is TV at
some
tv.org if you would like to know what
questions have been answered before so
that you don't have to repeat the
question you can download our app sum TV
is free you only have to create an
account with us there in the app and
you'll be able to see all the questions
that have been answered for our program
and all and also you will find series by
Passover sermons by Pastor CA and our
programs I'd like to know and other
things uh you can find also Pastor
boards study guides there for free on
our app so we highly encourage that you
also download our app
so for today again we have wonderful
questions but before before we do so
uh we would like to begin with a word of
prayer so let us bow our heads for
prayer
dear heavenly father we're trying heaven
we thank you very much for this program
we thank you for the opportunity to
start your word
your people have sent their questions
because they earnestly are looking for
answers they are digging into your word
and there are certain things that they
don't understand so we pray that you may
give us the wisdom to respond these
questions in the best possible way and
help us not twist the scriptures but to
stick to what is revealed in the name of
Jesus we pray amen amen
amen well again we have a question from
our brother Oliver who is that guy
and uh actually he has here three
questions that will take a good part of
this program and these questions are not
for him but for someone else
so here is how it goes God made
everything inherently inherently good
and make sure to give everyone free will
however he created Lucifer inherently
good
so the first question is why did God
create Lucifer yet knew he was going to
turn his back on God and he knew Lucifer
would destroy his creation but was
worried about his own reputation that
angels will see him as an aggressive
being who can't tolerate opposition
if he could have Zapped Satan out of
existence so let's go one by one this is
the first question a very complex and
not easy question why did God create
Lucifer if he knew that he would turn
his back on God
well
a number of things come
to mind God created a perfect being yes
the Bible gives no reason for norther's
spirit will probably give a reason for
sin
she says it is an entity for
which whose existence cannot be
justified in other words there's no
reason can be given for Lucifer he was
perfect until iniquity was found in him
now did God know that iniquity would be
found in him
God was not caught by surprise yet it
was in the plan of God to to to go ahead
with this creative experience
um a couple things come to mind you know
we talk about God we talk about us
um the Lord is suffering through this
also
God tried to
change Lucifer's mind
counsels were held with him to change
his mind but he did not
um it is in the in the
the
purview the mind of God to create
he that loveth not first John 4 North
not God for God is love there comes out
of love creation yes sometimes that
creation responds positively to you
sometimes that creation responds
negatively to you that's the key Point
here in this question yes
um and and and that is the risk you take
when you create unless you're going to
force uh uh love or obedience then
creation does carry with it the risk of
Disobedience and God chose to take that
risk knowing that he too was going to
have to suffer yes exactly you know
sometimes with when we ask this question
uh implicit even though it is my name
this might not be the intention but
there is an implicit idea
that in order for God to prevent the
entrance of sin so he would better not
create Lucifer well now if he would do
that he wouldn't even have to create any
other being because the safest way for
God to avoid sin coming into the
universe is just to stay by himself
don't create don't create precise
because as you just rightly mentioned
there is always a risk in creation when
you create free moral agents free moral
beings because uh
any of them can at one point choose to
rebel against God yes now God knew that
and he made provision for for that as
you mentioned the provision is called
Jesus Christ amen praise the Lord praise
God
chose God to be the answer to the sin
problem you know your your choices you
know you you almost
God doesn't need our sympathy certainly
but you know you look at God who is a
god of love a God who wants to create
you get this this this alternate way of
doing things in the universe the answer
would be as you have well said just
don't create just don't do anything but
that's not God you know he he that's not
how he functions on that's not how he is
and that wouldn't be love right and that
would be love you it'd be kind of a self
indulgent self-involved kind of thing
where okay these people out there might
act up so I'm not going to create them
just I won't be bothered with them well
that's that's just not God that's not
who's who he has shown himself to be
that's not who how love responds and of
course sin got us in love got us out you
know uh Lucifer got us in uh Christ got
us out by Roman says by one man we get
into the mess by one man one man we get
out you know that's right uh uh so the
answer was there uh the remedy was there
and thank God that it was pre-understood
when he said let us make man
then all of those
remedies that were going to be necessary
to get men back once he's in were also
put in place that's part of the
Everlasting Covenant praise the Lord
amen you know in the Judgment God is
going to show that Lucifer's rebellion
was unfounded there was no reason for it
he had given all the Privileges yeah and
God gave him all the opportunity that he
needed to repent he was even promised to
be reinstated to his original position
if he had repented in Ezekiel 28 verse
14. Oh yes Ezekiel 28 verse 14 he
occupied a high position ability in
heaven here we read you were the
anointed cherub who covers and some
scholar suggests that he was one of the
two cherubim that were in the presence
of God like the cherubim in the Ark of
the Covenant you are the anointed cherub
who covers I establish you you were on
the Holy Mountain of God
you walked back and forth in the midst
of the fiery Stones those are the Angels
and then as you alluded before you were
perfect in all your ways from the day
you were created till iniquity was found
in you so God did not create Satan he
created Lucifer correct but when he
rebelled he became Satan mm-hmm his
machinations the things he was saying
were given so much more weight because
of Ellen White says uh of the high
position he held yes you know he was he
was up there so high that um that
allowed him to get a hearing in heaven
and um he was corrupted by the Bible
says his Beauty looked at what he what
he had and uh the only person closer to
God was Christ himself and that seemed
to be a problem for him yeah so whatever
sin
is at its Essence it has something to do
with jealousy and without receiving
gratefully the position that God has
assigned to you now we won't be able to
answer in this side of Heaven all the
questions in regards to the entrance of
sin yeah and then why says that's a
mystery and we try to find an answer to
sin then it would no longer be sin so
there are certain things that we should
leave them there yes because we don't
understand all the yes integrate issues
yes in regards to this very easy to to
fall into speculation when you're
dealing with the subject about what we
don't have the essence or the or the
answer exactly now the second question
goes along with the first one it says
why didn't God give some sort of vision
to everyone instead of a few on what
would happen before punishing him so
everyone could see what he was
preventing
well actually God
he summoned all the Heavenly angels and
in in
um and Lucifer also and he he had he
outlined
the the consequences of sin and on all
the Angels had the opportunity to choose
between the their allegiance to God or
their allegiance to Satan God did not do
things in privacy he gave enough life
yes light to the Heavenly beings so that
they could make a decision now
um if if this would have prevented the
the issue and why God didn't take other
measures well God had to give time
for for the development of of of sin
some some people think that maybe God
could have just resolved this by
destroying Lucifer at the beginning or
he was just revealing a vision in an
extraordinary and Supernatural way you
know this is what is going to happen but
uh before that happened I just better
kill him right away and then we'd have
said we would have saved all this mess
here on Earth yes but uh that would be I
mean if I would see that from God I said
how do I know if that's really what is
going to happen how can I be sure okay
he's got he can see the future all right
but it would still leave doubts in the
minds of of many beings
because of the nature of the accusations
because of the way sin began to unfold
itself Lucifer proffering himself as the
victim uh
uh had God just wiped him out then there
would have been justification for that
that that manifestation oh he's the
victim see what God did uh if we get out
of line we're going to the same thing uh
one of the things that love
demands is is is that it that it be
given volitionally from the heart yes
can't be forced can't be coerced it's
got to come from the heart so
um God didn't want this errant view of
of his nature going throughout Heaven
and the only way to do that as you well
said is to allow time for the infection
to develop and of course once Christ
came
innocent sinless
and at his very birth
Satan tried to kill him and seven times
throughout his ministry Satan tried to
kill him and the last time it was
successful in killing him then all of
the
what's the word I want it would all of
doubt in the universe
was gone right because Christ's
character fully revealed Satan's
character that he was fully revealed yes
no doubt anymore in the minds of any in
the universe what Christ was who Christ
was what Satan was who Satan was amen
amen well said and the last question all
of them are related the last question
says why did hibanish Lucifer to the
Earth instead of finding something
creative unless destructive
I often hear this
but we don't find a direct evidence from
the Bible at least I don't find it if if
you do Pastor correct me if I am wrong
is that that God sent after he expelled
Lucifer from Heaven he sent him to the
Earth actually we don't know how much
time happened since he's uh his
expulsion from Heaven and the creation
of the Earth but we know that that the
creation of the earth took place after
the fall of Lucifer in heaven but um but
it wasn't that God sent him here and go
and tempt Adam and Eve right
we don't have a direct evidence from the
Bible it's very prophecy but what we do
find is an indication that he tried to
come by his own will after he saw that
this world had been created to try to
uh deceive the first couple and and put
his base or his kingdom from here in the
Earth yeah so that he can counteract uh
God's kingdom and we have an allusion to
that in Revelation chapter 20.
uh verse
three
um you know so some some versions here
translate for Nations worlds but he says
but he cast them into the bottomless pit
and shut him up and set a seal on him so
that he should deceive the Nations no
more till the thousand years were
finished but after these things he must
be released from a little for a little
while and then white comments on this
and she says that he would not have the
freedom to go and bother uh other worlds
so it is possible but I don't have
evidence clear evidence from the Bible
it is possible
that he tried
to deceive other worlds but they remain
faithful yeah and Ellen White actually
was given a vision he went to she went
to another world and she saw the
inhabitants of this world were more
beautiful than those on Earth and she
asked them why is it that you're more
beautiful and and they responded well we
have always stay faithful to the
Commandments of God so so there also
they were also tested yes that's where I
was going to go um
the answer as as much as an answer can
be given comes to us on the spirit of
Prophecy that he got a hearing here uh
he tried you know the language is not
causal Satan was cast out into the Earth
like he was a direct line from Heaven
thrown right down into the Earth no he
ended up here and he got a hearing here
he was able to
um uh to deceive Eve and um got a
foothold here is what I want and then of
course once he he got them to obey to
disobey God he claimed rulership of of
the earth
um but this is not the only place
according to prophecy where he tried to
get in but this is the only place where
he succeeded in getting it yeah and
maybe the text that might be used to
conclude that is revelation 12 because
he says that Satan and these Angels were
accustomed to the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him but that was not
actually the casting out of this verse
when he first fell this was the casting
out or his defeat at the cross at the
cross correct but the first when he was
actually
spelled from Heaven the Bible doesn't
say that God cast him to the Earth but
what the Bible says in Revelation
chapter 12 verses 3 and 4 and another
sign up here in heaven Behold a great
fiery red red dragon having seven heads
and ten horns and seven diadems on his
head his tail drew a third of the stars
of heaven and threw them to the Earth so
he was the one that threw them to the
earth and the dragon stood before the
woman so he was the one that chose the
Earth yes come and deceive and he came
with his angels with him
very good uh good question good answer
um let's see what so that's it we've
we've we've uh dealt with Oliver's one
to three questions and thank you Oliver
for writing uh when next you write and I
suspect you will again tell us where
you're writing from we'd like to know
we'd like to know
where where are you writing from all
right we've got time to just one more
Daniel okay very good so we have uh
Janice Vergara
and let's see if we she doesn't say
where she's writing from but we thank
you for sending in your question
my question is on Deuteronomy 4 13 and
maybe we should read that later
she says I understand that the Ten
Commandments
is not the old Covenant but it's part of
it but it seems that the Ten
Commandments is the Covenant at Mount
Sinai in Deuteronomy 4 13 and exodus 34
28. please help me understand because
the idea that the Ten Commandments is
not the Covenant at Sinai but is a part
of it uh seems contradictory to the
verses mentioned
okay so she has actually two questions
the second one is on Tiding but let's
deal with this first question first
so why don't we read first Deuteronomy 4
13 and then Exodus 34 28.
you have Deuteronomy 4 13 I have it the
Bible says so he declared to you his
Covenant which he commanded you to
perform the Ten Commandments and he
wrote them on two tables or tablets of
stone yes
now I'm reading Exodus 34 28 from the
new King James version so he was there
with the Lord 40 days and 40 nights he
neither ate bread nor drank water and he
wrote on the tablets the words of the
Covenant the ten commandments so the
words of the Covenant the ten
commandments so she says um
are the Ten Commandments the Covenant
the old Covenant or are only part of it
they are an expression of the the the
the the
Everlasting Covenant yes
you recall that once Moses went up to
the mountain
and uh received the Ten Commandments
meanwhile the Bible says the children of
Israel rose up to play
so
um
there is explained in in Exodus I think
it's 24 where they say all that thou I
said yes we will do and be obedient well
that lasted
about 40 days you know it just didn't
last that long it it was no blood that
was just okay we got it we'll do we'll
take care of this so that was not it uh
often called the old Covenant but the
Everlasting Covenant is an
all-encompassing phase first mentioned
in Genesis 3 15. it stated that God was
going to do that which was necessary to
reclaim his people yes and that of
course included the coming of of of
Christ
so the Ten Commandments is I think she
is correct is part of it but it's not
all it's not elephant it is not the
total of of the Everlasting Covenant
there is much more because uh it had to
include those Provisions made by heaven
for the Reclamation of God's people
which meant the uh the dying of Christ
on the cost yes so a covenant is is an
agreement if you will
in this case between God and his people
in Old Testament times between the
zuzarane and
um and the vasel okay so and that
agreement was based on Sun conditions
or a document a illegal document if you
will yes so the Ten Commandments are the
words of the commandant in what sense in
the sense that those are the conditions
to stay in the Covenant and that works
for both the Old and the New Covenant
because the the conditions were the same
okay the only difference is that the old
Covenant was based on the Promises of
men and the works of men the New
Covenant is based on the Promises of God
yes and and of course the material upon
which they are written and the material
exactly all Covenant tables of stone
that's right New Covenant tables of the
heart yes so it is the agreement it is
the the legal document if you will but
um but it's not the entire Covenant yes
as you just said it
okay good question uh it it presupposes
some thought into uh the uh the the
process of of reclaiming man from sin
and this subject of the Covenant is very
wide I mean we would require several
programs only dealing with this topic of
the covenants yes but uh we try to be
but as brief as possible just focusing
on this specific item uh then secondly
she asked
I'd like to know also how would you
reconcile giving Tides with a specific
10 of increase
according to Leviticus 27 verse 30 and
Deuteronomy 14 22 and Malachi 3 10
with giving according to what a man
purposes in his heart
second Corinthians 9 7.
is giving ties part of the ceremonial
law
so what is the difference is so maybe
the question will be here is second
Corinthians 9 7 is it talking about
tithing that's the first question that
jumps up in my mind and I I wanted to
read that at least because it probably
self-explains but let's take a look at
it I'm in second Corinthians we want
chapter nine and we want to look at
verse 7.
okay second Corinthians 9 verse 7.
so let's eat so let each one give as he
purposes in his heart not grudgingly or
of necessity for God loves a cheerful
Giver
so
what I see here is that Paul is talking
about offerings
because for the offerings there was not
a set percentage but for tithing God
said the 10 percent so the difference is
that offerings is what you purpose in
your heart but tithe is the 10 of the
increase
yes that would be the basic answer I
could give yes the The Book of Malachi
is very explicit about the tithe belongs
to God it is not it is not ours
um if you if you if you appropriate
tithe
that's not you're stealing from God
first of all you're embezzling so uh it
cannot fall into this category because
God claims an ownership for the tithe
that he does not for the offering yes
exactly the offering is volitional give
what you want but tithe is not
volitional it has been stated that it is
God's it belongs to God and if you take
it you are stealing from God exactly now
is giving tithe part of the ceremonial
law
would we include tithing as part of the
ceremonial law and this this would lead
me to another question that is not here
yes if it if it is part of the
ceremonial law then we would have to
conclude that uh at the cross right it's
gone it's gone it's not necessary it's
not binding um
I I don't see it as part of the ceremony
a lot simply because God puts a claim in
on the tithe the ceremonial law was
those rules laws are dealt with things
that pertained or look forward to the
coming of Christ yes giving of giving to
the Lord that which belongs to him
uh is not
bound up with the things that that
Christ is doing that's just being
obedient to the Lord uh in returning to
him those things that he says are his
exactly because he's still our creator
uh he's still a redeemer he still
blesses us uh so tithing is not part of
the ceremonial law actually in the New
Testament we don't see that the tie was
abolished we find evidence for example
uh Paul in First Corinthians 9 he talks
about tithing First Timothy chapter five
he also talks about tithing first second
Timothy chapter two I believe also so we
have several references in the New
Testament that speak of tithing as still
binding still binding the church yes yes
and if you love the Lord and want to see
his work progress then it's something
you do joyfully uh not grudgingly or of
necessity for indeed the Lord does Love
A Cheerful Giver amen and um uh and then
on top of that on top of giving God what
is his because when you've paid your
tithe you've only begun to return to the
Lord now on top of that you give
offerings that uh be speak your
gratitude for the goodness of the Lord
and that's what uh Second Corinthians
chapter 9 verse 7 is alluding to again
our time has fast slipped into eternity
allow us in closing to wish you both
Grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you again
soon bye bye
[Music]
foreign